oh hey you're a unit dorm room yeah I
folded your pants for you great little
war don't show anything it'll be off
maybe you should push the water next
time super helpful
don't be late to party tonight okay bye
happy birthday gotta flip book Maya I
got a row
hey yeah look in order to think in which
any can stop global warming
yeah I feel like I'm losing my mind you
sneaky little [ __ ] copyright thing
I've already lived through this day so
you can hear now but there is he okay
assuming that I believe any of this is
even possible framework car alarm the
way I see you have unlimited amount of
lives unlimited opportunities to sell
around murder someone supposed to keep
dying and so I figure out who my killer
is you want to live with you tomorrow
right whoever's killing you knows it's
your birthday
pretty much the entire schooling it's a
sign of major improvement
you should dead
you relive the same thing over and over
again
and see we really are
Oh
[Applause]
you
you